MALE SPEAKER: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for joining us.
This is part of our
Great Talks series.
If you'd like to learn
more, go to go/greattalks,
and we could add
you to our alias
and give you more invites
to events such as this.
I'd like to introduce
you to Max Boot.
He's also a contributor to
"New York Times," "Los Angeles
Times," and he recently wrote a
book called "Invisible Armies,"
about the epic history
of guerrilla warfare.
So without further ado, could
we please give Max a warm Google
welcome?
MAX BOOT: Thank you very much.
It's a pleasure to be here.
Normally, I'm more
used to speaking
to military audiences who
are just a tiny bit more
regimented.
But I like the informality here.
It's just kind of
cool to see the place.
And anyway, I'm
delighted to speak
about this little book,
or not-so-little book,
which if I could just borrow
Exhibit A right here, which
this gentleman is kindly--
I assume you bought it.
You didn't steal it, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I paid my $5.
MAX BOOT: OK.
You paid your $5.
That's actually a steal.
But this modest little tome,
which thankfully doesn't
weigh as much in
the paperback as it
did in the hardcover edition.
I tried to do something
very audacious and possibly
foolhardy, which was to cover
5,000 years of guerrilla
warfare history between two hard
cover and now two soft covers.
What I'm going to do here
today is even more audacious
and possibly even
more for foolhardy.
Because what I'm
going to try to do,
right here before
your very eyes,
is to summarize 5,000 years
of guerrilla warfare history
in about the next 25 minutes.
Now, for those of you
who are better at math
than I am, and I assume that
since this is Google that
means pretty much
everybody here,
that works out to, what,
about 200 years a minute,
something like that.
So fasten your seat belts
if you got any seat belts.
We're going to go for a very
rapid historical journey
into a subject which I think
has a great deal of relevance
as you pay attention to what's
going on in the world today.
Now, the question I get asked
most often about guerrilla
warfare is, what was
the first guerrilla war?
And that actually turns
out to be a question which
is very hard to answer,
especially when my clicker is
not working.
It's really almost
impossible to answer.
There we go.
Thank you
Because, in fact, guerrilla
warfare is as old as mankind.
There's a myth
that it was somehow
invented by the
Vietnamese or the Chinese
or somebody in the 20th century.
In fact, guerrilla warfare
is as old as mankind,
because tribal warfare is
essentially guerrilla warfare.
Tribes don't engage in the kind
of face-to-face frontal battle
which has been said
to characterize
the Western way of war
or conventional warfare
since at least the days
of the Greek Hoplites.
They don't stand there
and batter each other
into submissions.
Tribes prefer to engage
in hit and run raids,
launching a foray
into enemy territory,
into a neighboring
tribe's territory,
shooting some fire
arrows, raping, pillaging,
and then making their
escape before the warriors
of the other tribe can
make their appearance.
This is the oldest
form of warfare.
It's been around as long as
mankind has been on this earth.
And it is essentially
guerrilla warfare.
So guerrilla warfare long
predates conventional warfare.
In fact, conventional war is
a relatively recent invention.
It only arose about
3,000 BC in Mesopotamia
when you have the rise
of the first city-states.
Because by definition, you
can't have conventional armies
without a state
structure to support it.
You need somebody to
provide the tax base.
You need a hierarchy.
You need uniforms.
All the cool things are
we associate with armies?
Those are provided by states.
It needs a formal
structure to support it.
And that formal
structure only came
into being about
5,000 years ago.
But even when you had the
rise of the first city-states
in Mesopotamia, most of their
adversaries, most of the people
they were fighting, were
not other city-states.
Most of their wars were against
nomadic raiders from without
and rebels from within.
In other words, essentially
guerrilla warfare.
So we need to really
change the way
that we think about
this entire subject.
And that's part
of what I'm trying
to accomplish with this book.
Because our mental categories
are all screwed up.
We talk about unconventional
warfare, irregular warfare,
as if there's something
wrong with it,
as if this is not the way
you're supposed to fight,
as if you're actually
supposed to fight
in this conventional
way where you have
these massive
armies with uniforms
maneuvering on an
empty plain somewhere.
No.
Those kinds of conventional
wars have always
been the exception,
not the norm.
All the more so in
the modern world,
which I'll come to in a
minute, but throughout history,
unconventional, irregular
war has been the norm.
It is simply war.
This is the way war
has been fought.
So we need to change the way
we think about this subject.
It's not just the US Army
in Iraq and Afghanistan
that's had to deal with
guerrillas in the past decade
or so.
This is been a challenge
which has confronted
every great military force
throughout history, including
the greatest military force in
antiquity, the Roman legions.
Pretty formidable, even when
not led by Russell Crowe.
But we know that despite Russell
Crowe's inspired leadership,
Rome ultimately did fall.
And why did Rome fall?
That's the fall of Rome.
Rome, like the United States,
was a superpower without peer.
It did not have other superpower
rivals on its borders.
And yet it was
surrounded by enemies,
those whom the Romans
fondly called barbarians.
And who were the barbarians?
They were not conventional
military forces
like the Roman legions.
They were irregulars, who by and
large fought as, essentially,
raiders or guerrillas.
In fact, the downfall
of the Roman Empire
was brought about
by the invasion
into Western Europe
around 370 AD by the Huns,
led of course by their
fearsome leader, Attila.
Let me just read to you,
and you may well laugh.
By the way, nobody
actually knows
what Attila the Hun looked like.
There's not a single
portrait from real life.
This is a fanciful
19th century invention.
But we do know a little bit
about the way the Huns fought.
And let me just read you
a very brief description
from a Roman writer
in the fourth century.
He wrote of the Huns, "They are
very quick in their operations,
of exceeding speed and fond
of surprising their enemies.
They suddenly
disperse, then reunite.
And again, after having
inflicted vast loss
upon the enemy,
scatter themselves
over the whole plain in
irregular formations,
always avoiding a fort
or an entrenchment."
Now, I would submit
to you, that's
a pretty good description
of guerrilla warfare,
whether practiced in the
fifth century by the Huns
or as practiced today
by so many guerrilla
groups or terrorist
groups around the world,
from Syria to Afghanistan to
Iraq and to many other places.
That pattern of
hit and run raids,
of not standing still, of
not having front lines,
those are the characteristics
of guerrilla warfare
no matter how it's
been practiced
through the centuries.
Now, by stressing the
continuity and guerrilla
warfare over the
millennia, I don't
mean to suggest that
nothing has changed.
In fact, there have been
some significant changes.
The biggest changes of all,
to my mind, what really
distinguishes modern guerrilla
warfare or modern terrorism
from ancient guerrilla
warfare is really
the rise of
politics, propaganda,
public opinion-- the three Ps.
These are all characteristics
of modern, irregular conflicts.
And they were not very
important in the kind
of ancient guerrilla
warfare fought by the Huns.
The conflict which really
symbolizes the transition
from ancient to
modern, to my mind,
is our very own
revolution, which
was fought, we should
recall, not just with muskets
and swords but also
with broadsides,
like Thomas Payne's famous
bestseller, "Common Sense."
When we think about the battles
of the American Revolution,
we tend to think about battles
like Lexington and Concord,
where the Read Coats are very
chagrined to find these Yankee
rascals slithering around
on their bellies and firing
at them from behind
trees and rocks
and doing all sorts
of other things
that were considered to
be not quite cricket.
They were, in fact,
using guerrilla warfare.
And that was certainly
a significant part
of the American Revolution.
But ultimately, it was not
where the American Revolution
was decided.
The way I remember
the Revolution
being taught in school-- and
I'm old enough that it in my day
the Revolution was
still taught in school.
I seem to recall that
the narrative essentially
ends around the Battle
of Yorktown in 1781,
when Lord Cornwallis surrendered
about 7,000 regulars to General
Washington.
That was the last major battle
of the American Revolution.
But it did not have to
be the last major battle.
And this is a point
that I think is usually
missing from accounts of
the War of Independence.
Because in fact, even
after Yorktown, even
after Saratoga before
that, the British empire
was still the mightiest
military force in the world.
They still had tens of thousands
of troops in North America,
tens of thousands more in
other parts of the empire.
And they could have
hired tens of thousands
more mercenaries from
the German states
as they had previously done.
I can assure you that
if our ancestors,
if the founding fathers had been
fighting not the British empire
but the Roman Empire,
the story would not
have had a happy ending.
Because the Romans did not
take defeat sitting down.
They did not give up.
Almost certainly, they
would have come back,
and Washington,
Jefferson, Adams,
and the other
founding fathers would
have been crucified,
quite literally.
The fact that this
did not happen
is because of an institution
that the Romans did not
have to worry much
about, a parliament.
In fact, I would argue to
you that the turning point,
the decisive point of
the American Revolution
did not occur at Saratoga or
Yorktown or any other battle
in North America.
It actually happened
in the House of Commons
in 1782, where on February 28,
1782, a decisive vote was held.
By a very thin
margin, 234 to 215--
it was that close--
the House of Commons
voted to discontinue offensive
operations in North America.
This was a stinging blow to Lord
North and his hard line Tory
ministry.
It in fact led to the
downfall of Lord North
and the rise of a Whig
ministry under Lord Rockingham
that was committed
to conciliation
with their American brethren.
Now, it's hard to overstate
how incredibly important.
this event was.
Because here you had this
great power, the superpower
of its day, that had the
capacity to keep fighting,
but chose not to do so
because its public opinion had
turned against the war.
This was not something that
happened in centuries past.
But it's happened quite a
few times in centuries since,
most recently in Vietnam.
It's exactly what the fighters
that we face in Afghanistan
are trying to achieve.
They know they can't
defeat us on a battlefield,
all they're trying to do is to
change American public opinion
to lead to a pull
of American forces.
And guess what?
I think they're probably
going to be successful.
This is a strategy
that really dates back
to our own War of Independence.
And it's one that has influenced
generation after generation
of insurgent
strategists ever since,
including this gentleman, who
was the foremost guerrilla
strategist of the 20th century.
Mao Tse-tung wrote, in 1938,
one of the great classics
of guerrilla
warfare, which I hope
is on all of your
nightstand tables
and you study it
religiously every night,
a little volume called
"On Protracted War," which
can be found, of course, in
his "Little Red Book," which
I'm sure all of you have.
What Mao wrote and produced was
a document telling his troops
how to fight a much more
powerful, entrenched adversary.
And some of the advice he
offered included the following.
He said that people
are like water,
and the Army is like fish.
He stressed the need to keep
the closest possible relations
with the common people.
He told his troops, "Be
courteous and polite.
Pay for all articles.
Establish latrines a safe
distance from people's houses."
And so forth and so on.
Why was Mao offering
this advice?
Was it because he was a
soft-hearted humanitarian who
really have the welfare
of the people at heart?
I don't think so.
Morally, I would argue,
there was probably
very little to distinguish
Mao from someone
like Attila the Hun.
And yet Mao was
telling his troops
to behave in a very
different way from the way
that the Huns had behaved
more than 1,000 years earlier.
Why was that?
Because Mao understood
that the nature of warfare
had changed in the
modern age, that you
could no longer fight this
nomadic style of warfare
that the Huns had
pursued in ancient times.
In the modern era, you had to
take account of public opinion,
whether you liked it or not.
In order to create a
force powerful enough
to overthrow an entrenched
government like the Kuomintang,
you had to be able
to control base areas
where you could tax the
people, where you could train
your troops, where you could
spread propaganda, where
you could do everything
necessary to raise
a powerful military force.
And to do that, you had to keep
the people on your side, which
is why he gave very
strict instructions on how
his troops should behave
with the common people.
That's an indication of how
much more powerful and pertinent
public opinion is
today than it was
in the early days of
guerrilla warfare.
Of course, public opinion
is even more important
when it comes to
terrorism, which
the anarchists of
the 19th century
defined as propaganda
by the deed.
That's because terrorists have
very little military power,
even less than guerrillas.
They cannot possibly hope
to topple an existing regime
by force.
The most they can
hope to do is to stage
a few spectacular attacks
like this one, which
they know will
generate headlines
and they hope will lead to
a change in public opinion
and to move the public policy
in a direction that they favor.
Which is by the way why
there was almost no terrorism
before the second half
of the 19th century.
Because there was no way for
them to get their message out
before the rise
of the mass media,
which was enabled by
high- speed printing
presses, the telegraph,
and, of course, later,
radio, television, the
internet, satellite TV.
All these media are tailor
made for terrorists,
because essentially what
they're trying to do
is to stage acts that
will create publicity.
And so they have a way
to get their story out.
This is something that
the foremost terrorists
the modern times recognized.
Osama bin Laden once wrote that
the media war is as much as 90%
of the whole in the
waging of jihad.
That's how much
importance he ascribed
to this particular
method of fighting.
I would argue that the rising
power of public opinion
helps to explain one of
the interesting trends
that I uncovered in the
course of my book research.
Most of that book is just
a straight out narrative
of 5,000 years of history built
around colorful and exciting
personalities, like Michael
Collins, Orde Wingate, TE
Lawrence, and many others.
But at the end of
the book, I make,
what is for me, a very
rare foray, in fact,
a unique foray, into the
realm of social science.
Because I compiled at
the end of the book
a database of insurgencies
since 1775 coded for outcome.
And what does that
database show?
It shows that rebels have
been getting more successful.
Prior to 1945, insurgents
were winning about 20%
of their campaigns.
Since 1945, they've been winning
about 40% of their campaigns.
Now, what accounts for
that rising success rate?
Part of it is due to the spread
of ever more powerful weaponry,
which I'll talk
about in a minute.
But I would argue to
you the largest factor
is simply the rising
power of public opinion.
That's kind of the trump
card that insurgents have.
That's a way that they can
influence a much more powerful
adversary and convince
them to stop fighting,
even if they have not been
beaten on the battlefield.
And by the way, this
is not only an issue
for democracies like ours,
although it obviously is.
In the modern world, it's an
issue for dictatorships, too.
Just ask Muammar Gaddafi.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You can't ask Gaddafi,
because he's dead.
And why is he dead?
Because he tried to put down an
uprising in the tried and true
fashion of dictators everywhere
throughout history, fire
and sword, killing
people left and right.
It didn't work, however.
Why didn't it work?
Because in the modern age, his
atrocities, or the atrocities
he was about to
carry out, received
international publicity
and mobilized a coalition
of outside states led
by the United States
to come in and help the rebels.
And that ultimately led to
Gaddafi's death and downfall.
That's an example of how
public opinion matters
in the modern age, even
for countries where
they don't have elected regimes.
But it really matters
for countries like ours
or Israel or Britain
or others, where
you do have elected governments.
So this has been a game changer
in the realm of guerrilla
warfare.
And it's really been a huge
advantage for insurgents.
But, having said
that, I don't think we
should go too far in
the other direction.
And certainly
after World War II,
there was a tendency
to deify guerrillas
as these 10-foot-tall
superhumans who could not
possibly be defeated
by military force.
A lot of that was a result of
the well publicized success
of a few high-profile insurgents
like Mao Tse-tung, Ho Chi
Minh, Fidel Castro.
But let's not lose sight
of the larger picture.
Remember the statistic I cited
to you just a minute ago.
Even if in the post-'45 era
insurgents are winning 40%
percent of their campaigns,
what's the flip side of that?
Obviously, they're
still losing 60%.
They're still more
likely than not to fail.
And to illustrate that
part of the story,
let me cite to you the example
of a man whose picture once
adorned every dorm room
wall on the planet,
and actually probably still
adorns every dorm room wall
at my alma mater, which is Cal.
How did Che Guevara become
such an idol of youth
and such a boon for makers
of t-shirts and posters?
It wasn't just because
he had a great beret.
It was because of the success
that he and hi friend Fidel
Castro had in the 1950s in
overthrowing the Batista regime
in Cuba, which indeed was
a very impressive campaign,
because you had a few hundred
rebels in the mountains of Cuba
without a lot of heavy
weaponry and without,
by the way, great hygiene,
and lots of beards.
But they were
fighting a regime that
was supported by the
United States, Batista, who
had an army of something like
20,000 men, who had tanks, who
had airplanes, who
had naval ships, all
of the paraphernalia
of modern warfare.
And so the fact that Fidel
and Che and their crew
managed to march into Havana
seems pretty impressive.
And it was pretty impressive.
But it becomes
more understandable
if you look a little closer and
you understand that by the time
he fell at the end
of the 1950s, Batista
had lost all legitimacy.
He was widely despised by
all sectors of Cuban society,
even the chamber of commerce
had turned against him.
Now that's a bad sign, when
the chamber of commerce
turns against an
existing regime.
And so that's why
it was possible
that this corrupt, unpopular,
illegitimate, unelected ruler--
that's why it was
possible for him
to be overthrown by a relatively
small band of fighters.
But like many victorious
generals over the centuries,
Che suffered from a
severe case of hubris.
He imagined he could
replicate elsewhere
the success that he
had had in Cuba, which
is why in 1966 he
went to Bolivia.
And that's Che right there,
the very bearded gentleman
in the lower part of the photo,
trying to foment a revolution.
But in Bolivia he found a
very different situation
from the one that had
confronted him in Cuba.
Because, in fact, the leader
of Bolivia at the time
was not this unpopular,
unelected autocrat.
Bolivia actually had a popular
left-wing elected president,
who had already instituted
land reform, which
was the chief
Marxist calling card.
Whereas by contrast,
Che came in with a
handful of outsiders,
not a Bolivian among them.
They didn't even speak the
local Indian languages.
In fact, I think
it's fair to say
that during his time in
Bolivia, Che's favorite,
closest friend was
his mule Chico.
So it's not a great surprise
that before long, he
was hunted down by these
guys, Bolivian army rangers
advised by US Army Special
forces and the CIA.
And this was the end of
the great Che Guevara,
his corpse being
poked by his enemies.
Now, I would submit
to you that even
if an insurgent as
legendary as Che Guevara
could ultimately be hunted
down, defeated, and killed,
there is no insurgency so
strong it could not be defeated.
The question is, how?
Well, we are very
lucky in this regard
that two of the great
powers of Europe
conducted, for our
benefit, a controlled
experiment in
counterinsurgency in the 1950s.
On the one hand, you had
the French in Algeria
from 1954 to 1962.
On the other hand, you
had the British in Malaya
from 1948 to 1960.
And they fought in
very different styles.
The French really exemplified
the fire and sword,
the heavy-handed mailed fist
approach to counterinsurgency,
whereas the British
approach in Malaya
was more emblematic of what
came to be known as the Hearts
and Minds school of
counter insurgency.
Now let me explain a little
bit more about what that means.
If you want to find out what
the French did in Algeria,
you don't have to stand
here and listen to me.
You should go home and
rent, if you haven't already
done so, that wonderful movie,
"The Battle of Algiers,"
which is actually a very
accurate depiction of what
happened during the battle
in Algiers in the late 1950s.
At that time, the
Algerian insurgents
were setting off
bombs in Algiers,
the capital of Algeria.
And they were killing civilians,
including European civilians.
The local security forces
seemed helpless to stop
this wave of terror.
And so in desperation,
the French authorities
turned to the elite of the
French army, the 10th Parachute
Division under
General Jacques Massu.
The paratroopers swiftly
marched into the kasbah,
the native quarter of
Algiers, and began rounding up
tens of thousands of young
men for interrogation
to find out who were
the terrorists lurking
in their midst.
Now we know what happened in
these interrogation centers,
in part because of the testimony
of this man, Henri Alleg,
who was not himself Algerian.
He was actually
French, a French Jew,
but he was also a communist, and
he ran a Republican newspaper
in Algiers, which
was crime enough
to get him arrested
by the paratroopers.
And he later wrote a short
book describing his ordeal.
We're all familiar with
ancient instruments of torture,
like the rack or
the iron maiden.
Well, Henri Alleg
was introduced to
a new and modern and
fiendish form of torture,
are known as the gegene, which
was simply a hand-crank dynamo
originally developed to
power field telephones.
And it had a couple of clips,
which you can see on the right,
and a handle you could turn.
And the faster you
turned that handle,
the more electricity comes out.
This was a favorite
instrument of interrogation
used by the French
security forces in Algeria.
Henri Alleg described
what happened to him
when he was dragged into
an interrogation center.
And he first had the
clips applied to his ear
and to his finger.
He wrote, "A flash of lightning
exploded next to my ear.
And I felt my heart
racing in my breast.
I struggled, screaming."
Then, when he still would not
tell the paratroopers what
they wanted to hear, they took
one of the clips off is ear
and attached it to his penis.
He wrote that his "body
shook with nervous shocks,
getting stronger in intensity."
And still, he was tough,
this newspaper editor.
He still would not tell them
what they wanted to know.
And so they took him down
off the interrogation table,
they beat him, and they
dragged him into another room
where he experienced
another form of torture
that they called the
[? touillot ?], what
we know better as waterboarding.
He wrote, "I had the
impression of drowning
and a terrible agony of death
itself took possession of me."
After this ordeal, he was
tossed into a cell, still naked,
left to spend the night
on a barbed wire mattress,
listening to the screams
and thuds of other detainees
getting similar treatment in
this interrogation facility.
It's sometimes said that
torture doesn't work.
Don't you believe it.
At least in the case of
Algeria, it was very tactically
effective, because using
such brutal methods
of interrogation, the
French paratroopers
cracked the entire terrorist
infrastructure in Algiers
in a matter of months.
By the end of
1957, no more bombs
were going off in Algiers.
And so the French generals
and the paratroopers
could congratulate
themselves that they
had won their war on terror.
Or had they?
Well, as we know with
the benefit of hindsight,
they want a short-term
tactical victory
at the cost of long-term,
strategic defeat.
Because there was no
way to conceal what
was going on in this city not
far from the shores of Europe.
Some people who were
tortured, like Henri Alleg,
came forward to
tell their story.
And gradually the
new seeped out.
And as the people in France
began to read headlines
about what their security forces
were doing in their name, how
their own army was acting
just like the Gestapo,
support for the war
effort plummeted.
And not just in France, but
all around the world, including
in the United States,
where John F. Kennedy made
a memorable speech against the
French war effort in Algeria.
As a result of that, de Gaulle,
by then President of France,
realized that it
was going to cost
too much to try to
hold onto Algeria.
And so in 1962, he granted
Algeria its independence.
And pretty much all of
the European settlers
had to leave or
risk being killed.
This was a shattering
defeat for France.
And it's an illustration
of the dangers
of being overly heavy
handed in your approach
to counterinsurgency,
because that can backfire,
as it in fact did for
the French in Algeria.
Now, as it happens, on the
other side of the world,
the British were trying
a very different approach
to counterinsurgency in Malaya.
Gerald Templer took over as
commander of British forces
and as governor general
in Malaya in 1952.
When he arrived, he found
a very dire situation.
The Malayan races Liberation
Army, the communist group
that was fighting British
rule, was blowing up trains.
They were attacking
rubber plantations.
They were in the midst
of a wave of terror
that many feared would
drive the British out.
In fact, the very car,
the very Rolls Royce
in which General Templer drove
from the airport in Kuala
Lumpur to government
house, the very car
was riddled with bullets.
Because just a few
months previously,
his predecessor, the
previous governor general,
had been assassinated
in that very vehicle.
That must have been
a sobering ride.
And it would have been very easy
if, under those circumstances,
Templer decided that he had
no choice but to terrorize
the population
into acquiescence.
But that's not what he
did, because he understood
that the key to victory was not
in terrorizing the population,
but in controlling
the population.
And so how did he go about
controlling the population?
Well, he undertook a
number of initiatives,
including the creation of
these new villages where
many of the Chinese
squatters, who
were at the heart of the
rebellion, were relocated.
Because Templar understood
that these Chinese squatters
who had no citizenship,
no land rights, little
in the way of livelihood,
they were prime recruits
for communist agitators.
And so to take away the
manpower base of the insurgency,
the British moved large
numbers of these squatters
into these fortified
new villages
where they had access to
clean water, schools, fields
to till, hospitals.
And oh, by the way, they
were also surrounded
by guards and barbed
wire to prevent
them physically from
supporting the insurgency.
The British did
other things as well.
For example, they sent aircraft
over fly rebel held areas.
Not the bomb them,
but to drop leaflets
calling on them to surrender.
Some of them were even
equipped with loudspeakers
that would call out individual
rebels on the ground
by name, which was a very
spooky and effective tactic.
The British also sent SAS teams.
Once they had pinpointed
the rebel locations
to execute very precise raids
that did not hurt civilians,
but would wind up
rounding up the leadership
of the insurgency.
They even imported headhunters
from Borneo to act as trackers.
But at the end of the day,
what Templer understood
was that the war was going to
be won or lost among the people.
And Templer is famous
for two sayings, which
still characterize his
school of counterinsurgency.
He said, "The shooting side
of the business is only 25%
of the trouble.
And the other 75%
lies in getting
the people the
country behind us."
He also said, "The answer lies
not in pouring more troops
into the jungles, but
in the hearts and minds
of the people."
There's that famous phrase.
That's where it first
became popular, was
when Templer used it.
And it's often been misused
to think that somehow
the counterinsurgency
forces are in a battle
to win the love and
affection of the population.
That's kind of how we approach
things in Iraq and Afghanistan,
where we showered
tens of billions
of goodies on the populace,
with water treatment
plants, hospitals, schools,
all sorts of great stuff
to get them to love us
and reject the insurgency.
Well, as it turns out,
that doesn't really work.
Because while people may
like having schools or water
treatment plants or
whatever, they're
not going to support you if
they're going to get killed.
There has to be basic security
before any of that other stuff
can come into play.
And that's something
that Templer understood,
that you had to have security.
But he also understood
that you would not
have ultimate and lasting
security unless there
was a reason for the people
to support the government.
He understood you could
not keep the populace down
at bayonet point indefinitely.
And so he had to
give them a reason
to support the
British war effort.
And so what did he do?
He basically made a deal
with the people of Malaya.
He said, if you support
us, the British,
against this
communist uprising, we
will grant you, the people
of Malaya, independence.
Now, that was something
that the Malayans wanted.
It gave them a reason
to support the British.
I mean, it seems
like a no-brainer.
And yet, at the very same
time, the French in Algeria
were trying to make
the Algerians fight
for a continuation of
French colonial role.
No wonder they lost.
By contrast, the strategy that
Templer employed in Malaya,
of providing security while
at the same time providing
legitimacy, that has
really characterized
most successful
counterinsurgency efforts
in the modern world, whether
in Northern Ireland, Colombia,
Iraq, or elsewhere.
Now, the final part
of my presentation,
I want to do
something important,
which is to answer the
question some of you may have,
I know a question a lot of
people in Washington have,
which is, so what?
Why does any of
this stuff matter?
I mean, if you listen to a lot
of people inside the Beltway,
they'll tell you
counterinsurgency
is so yesterday.
Been there, done
that, didn't like it.
We moved on to something else.
We're out of Iraq.
We're getting out
of Afghanistan.
We're not going to
get involved in Syria.
We're pivoting to the Pacific.
We're not going
to do these kinds
of ankle biter,
brushfire type of wars.
We're going to get ready for
the big one against China
or somebody else.
Well, that's the
thinking of the day.
The problem is reality
doesn't necessarily cooperate.
I mean, it would be wonderful
if our enemies fought us
in exactly the way
that we preferred.
It would be great if
every enemy that we
face would put a big
tank army out there
in the desert with a
big "hit me" sign on it.
We know how to do
that kind of war.
Unfortunately, we can't count
on every single adversary being
quite as obliging
as Saddam Hussein.
Most of the world has
gotten the message.
You're not going to
get too far by fighting
the American armed
forces in the open field.
And so therefore,
they've resorted
to other ways of
fighting us that
have proven more
successful, essentially
to using guerrilla
and terrorist tactics.
That has a much higher
percentage chance
of prevailing against
the superpower.
That's why we've seen so much
of it in the last few decades.
That's why we're going
to see a lot more of it.
It's not going away, as the
terrible attack on the Boston
Marathon should remind us.
It's not just the
threat in distant lands,
it's a threat
right here at home.
In fact, one of the
really disturbing trends
in the last 100 years
suggest that attacks
like the one at
the Boston Marathon
or even the terrible attack
of 9/11, that may only
be a small taste of what we
have to fear in the future.
Because one of the big
trends in the last 100 years
is that the amount
of destructive power
available to the
individual is increasing.
I mean, think about it.
A century ago,
when Western armies
were campaigning
against guerrillas
on the plains of the Midwest,
for example, or in Africa
or elsewhere, their enemies
were usually armed with nothing
more than bows and arrows,
maybe a few muskets or rifles.
Today, by contrast, there is no
corner of the world so remote
that every young man
doesn't have access
to an AK-47 or rocket-propelled
grenade, explosives,
all these very simple,
low-tech infantry weapons,
which have nevertheless
taken a terrible toll
among American troops
in Afghanistan and Iraq.
And what might the future bring?
Well, I don't mean to
seem unduly alarmist,
but we do have to contemplate
the possibility that terrorists
get their hands on weapons
of mass destruction.
That's a pretty
terrifying scenario,
because I'm very much concerned
that George Clooney may not
be there to save us
in the nick of time.
And what happens if George
Clooney is not there?
Well, let me leave you
with one slide here, which
is from a magazine that
I'm sure all of you
read and probably have
piled up in your basements.
This is of course the
International Journal
of Health Geographics, the 2007
issue, if it jogs your memory.
This was a study that was done
by a team of scientists of what
would happen if various-sized
nuclear devices were set off
in various American cities.
I don't want to
unduly alarm you,
so I'm not showing you what
would happen to where you live,
I'm showing you all what
would happen to where I live,
because I happen to
live in Manhattan, right
about the mid-center there.
This is a chart that illustrates
a possible 20-kiloton device
exploding in lower Manhattan.
A 20-kiloton device, I would
add, is not very powerful.
It's about the same
size as the bombs that
leveled Hiroshima
and Nagasaki in 1945.
It's a relatively
primitive weapon
by the standards
of atomic weapons.
And yet, what would be
the consequence of this?
Well, as you can see, anybody
who lives south of Yonkers
is going to be in deep trouble.
The study actually
estimates that something
like more than 600,000 people
would be killed and 1.6 million
would be injured.
That's a pretty sobering
thing to think about.
But that is, in fact,
the potential future
of low-intensity conflict.
I don't mean to be
overly alarmist here,
and I certainly
don't mean to suggest
this is going to
happen tomorrow.
I hope it never happens.
But we have to consider
the terrible possibility
that it could happen, or
something similar could happen.
And that's why we cannot
afford to ignore low-intensity
conflict.
We can pretend that it's
not an issue for us.
We can pretend it's going away.
But it's not.
It's going to be here.
It's always been here,
always will be here.
And the threat is
only getting worse.
That's why I think it's all the
more imperative to understand
the history, to understand
the doctrine and the potential
of this kind of warfare.
And that's why I
wrote this book.
And I hope by reading it people
can understand a little bit
better the nature of the
dominant military threat
that we face going
forward, which
is identical to the dominant
military threat we've
faced in centuries past.
So with that, let me
stop talking at you.
And I assume we have
time for some questions.
Or hope we have
time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Can you say
if there's a correlation
between-- on the
one hand, you say
guerrilla warfare is
much more successful
because of the rise of media.
Is there a correlation
between the reigning powers
having less control or less
dominance over their economies
as well?
So what I mean by that is,
like, if everybody was already
involved in the army, like
if you had mass conscription,
then there was nobody
else left to win over.
It's a lot harder to
win over a soldier
than it is to win over
an unaffected a person.
Whereas today,
our volunteer army
is a very small
percentage of the US.
And so you can win
over the population,
because they're not
necessarily part
of the war effort against it.
And they also have
a lot more money
and they can actually speak
out against government
then maybe serfs could
have in the 1500s.
Is there anything to
suggest that that's true?
MAX BOOT: It's an
intriguing idea.
But just off the
top of my head, I'm
not instantly convinced
of that analysis.
Because when you
think about it, look
at what happened with
the Bolshevik Revolution
in Russia, for example.
A lot of what occurred
among disaffected soldiers
and sailors who were
mutinying against the tsar
because they were on the
losing end of a conflict.
Or if you look at what happened
in Vietnam, which was the worst
military defeat in our history.
The reason why that occurred
is because public opinion
turned against the war.
And a lot of the reason
why public opinion turned
against the war was because
we had a large conscript army.
And so lots of young
men and their families
were afraid that were going
to be drafted and sent
to Vietnam, which
they didn't want to.
And that really
was what generated
a lot of the momentum for
the anti-war movement, which
I think ultimately resulted
in America's departure
from Southeast Asia.
And so in that case,
having a large army
backfired and actually
made it easier
to rally public opinion
against the war.
In general, I would say that
successful counterinsurgency
campaigns over the centuries,
including dating back
to Roman times,
tend to be conducted
by relatively small,
professional, all-volunteer
forces.
In fact, that was
a lot of the reason
why the Roman army in the
first century moved away
from being an army
of citizen soldiers
called away from their
farms for a fighting season
and moved towards being a
professional force made up
essentially of mercenaries,
professional soldiers,
because these kinds of
campaigns take so long.
In fact, the average
insurgency in my analysis
in the post-1945 period takes
about 10 years to defeat.
It's a very long time.
And it's hard to
imagine calling away
draftees for a campaign
of that duration.
It's also a very inglorious
and tough type of fighting.
And so historically, the kind
of force which has always
done the best at that
kind of warfare, tends
to be a volunteer force,
which doesn't mind campaigning
for year after year
on distant frontiers,
like for example the US
Army fighting Indians
throughout the 19th century.
Sir?
AUDIENCE: I think it's guerrilla
warfare month at Google,
because on Wednesday I'm
hosting David Kilcullen here.
MAX BOOT: Oh, good.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
finished his book yet, but--
MAX BOOT: Give Dave my regards.
AUDIENCE: --I believe his
thesis is that urban guerrilla
warfare will be a much, much
larger factor in the future.
I'm almost done with
your book, by the way,
but it's on Kindle so I
can get you to sign it.
But do you agree with his
thesis about urban warfare?
MAX BOOT: I would say that
it's probably the case, simply
because insurgents typically
operate among the people.
And people in the modern world
increasingly live in cities,
including these huge,
dysfunctional cities
throughout the Third World,
which can become prime breeding
grounds for uprisings.
The only caveat I
would issue, however,
is that historically,
urban insurgencies
have not been successful.
It's actually very
hard for me to think
of any examples of
urban insurgencies
that have succeeded.
Most of them like, the
Paris Commune in 1871,
wind up going down in bloodshed.
Or more recently, in 2007,
2008, US and Iraqi troops
took back Baghdad
from al Qaeda in Iraq
and from the [INAUDIBLE]
and assorted other fighters.
It's very hard.
The problem is that in
cities, traditionally,
it's very hard to have the kind
of organization and training
that you need to have an
effective fighting force,
because you're always
surrounded by other people.
So I mean, just think
about, like, where
would you go to
practice marksmanship,
for example, without somebody
finding out about it?
How would you make bombs?
I mean, you could
do it, but you have
to be very
surreptitious about it.
Whereas, historically, most
successful guerrilla movements
have operated in the
countryside, where they're
able to control actual
chunks of territory,
what they call
liberated territory.
And there they're essentially
able to have their own shadow
government and to build up
a force that in the Maoist
conception gradually encircles
the cities and takes power.
Traditionally, in urban
areas what you've had
is revolutions or coup d'etats
or people power uprisings,
like in the Philippines
in 1986, or the uprising
you had against Mubarak,
for example, in Egypt.
Whereas actual protracted
insurgencies have,
maybe Dave will
contradict me, but it's
hard for me off the
top my head to think
of a single, actual,
successful urban insurgency
throughout history.
But that doesn't mean
it's not going to happen.
And it doesn't mean that even
if they're not successful
that insurgents are still
going to fight in the cities.
They will, because that's
where the people are.
And that's where you'll
see battles in the future.
No doubt about it.
AUDIENCE: What do you think
drives the duration of never
ending conflicts like
that, of Colombia.
What are your thoughts
on what should
be the authorities' strategy?
MAX BOOT: Well, I
would say that there
is one commonality
among all countries that
have protracted insurgencies.
It's not a population
youth bulge.
It's not scarcity of water.
It's not a particular
religious group.
It's not having
certain pocket number
of people in urban versus
rural areas, whatever.
All these factors that
people cite-- largely BS,
because there's a lot
of counterexamples.
I think the one
universal defining
trait of all countries that
have protracted insurgencies
is bad government.
That's what drives
an insurgency.
Because if you have an
effective government
that response to the
needs of the people,
you have Switzerland.
You have countries where
it's unimaginable to have
an effective uprising.
If you look at
actual uprisings that
are occurring in places like
Iraq, Afghanistan, Syria,
Somalia, Libya, Congo,
many other places,
what do they all have in common?
The government sucks.
That's what they have in common.
The government cannot provide
for the welfare and well being
of the people.
It cannot protect the people.
It cannot deliver
basic services.
And that's what creates an
opening for people to rise up.
Now, sometimes,
you have uprisings
that are driven by
ethnic antagonisms.
But even there, I would
argue, bad government
is at the heart of the problem.
Because what you
have is a government
that does not
respond to the needs
of a particular ethnic,
religious, or sectarian group.
And so they feel alienated
from the government
and decide to break off and
try to form their own country.
But that's the common factor.
Colombia, where I visited
a number of times,
has actually been one
of the great success
stories in counterinsurgency,
because FARC
is a really a shadow of itself.
Over the course the
last decade, starting
under the inspired leadership
of President Uribe,
the Colombian armed
forces and police
have done a tremendous
job of instituting
this population-centered
counter-insurgency strategy,
which is really
beating back the FARC.
But to the extent that
FARC is still breathing--
and they're negotiating now,
so they may end the war.
But to the extent that
FARC is still a factor,
it's because out there in
the hinterlands of Colombia,
there is not
effective government.
That the central
government in Bogota
has never controlled
all the rural areas.
And that's what allows narco
traffickers and FARC, who
are often working together, to
continue operating out there.
And the challenge
for the government
is how to provide effective
governance in those areas,
because it's ultimately
going to be governance.
While you've got
to have security,
you also have to
have governance.
Those two go hand in hand.
So you basically have to be
able to have representatives
of the government out
there 24/7 responding
to the needs of the people
and protecting them.
And until they can
do that, there's
going to be space for an
insurgency to continue.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the talk.
I wanted to talk about Syria.
After 10-odd years of war
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
there's a really big
push to not-- people
don't want to intervene, right?
And at the same
time, you saw what
I would have to judge as
a relatively successful
intervention in Libya,
just in terms of air power.
And I was wondering
what your thoughts are
on not having boots
on the ground,
or just limiting something to
an air strike, and how effective
that can be in countries,
particularly Syria,
and what's different
in Syria versus Libya.
MAX BOOT: We tend to
veer from interventionism
to non-interventionism.
And obviously, in
the last decade,
we were pretty interventionist.
And most people weren't
that happy with the result
in Iraq and Afghanistan,
which of course included,
unfortunately, thousands
of soldiers killed and tens
of thousands wounded.
And so the result of that is
we want to stay out of Syria.
Well, we saw in the case
of Iraq and Afghanistan
how our intervention
can backfire and produce
some negative consequences.
But in the case
of Syria, I think
we're seeing how our
non-intervention can also
backfire and produce
negative consequences.
And the situation
there is about as
dire as can be imagined,
with over 100,000 people
having been killed and another
5,000 or so dying every month.
And from our
strategic standpoint,
I think it's a very dangerous
situation, because it's
easy for people to
say, we don't really
want to support either side.
On one side, you've got Assad
and the Iranians and Hezbollah.
On the other side, on
the popular conception,
you've got a bunch
al Qaeda groups.
Now, in reality, the
intelligence estimates
are that the al Qaeda-affiliated
groups are only about 20%
of the insurgency.
But they are significant factor.
There's no question about it.
And so a lot of people are
basically saying, well,
why should we help either side?
And I think that's essentially
President Obama's position.
The problem with that analysis
is by not helping either side,
by not doing anything
to get involved,
we're basically
allowing those two sides
to carve up Syria between them.
On the one hand, you have
this Hezbollah stronghold.
On the other hand, you have
this al Qaeda stronghold
in northern Syria
and crossing over
into Iraq and Anbar province.
To my mind, that's
about as bad an outcome
as you could possibly imagine.
Because both Hezbollah and
the Iranians and the Qods
force, their our enemies.
Al Qaeda is obviously
our enemies.
And so both groups
are going to be
able to use Syrian territory
to organize and possibly
to export jihadists
around the world.
Because this has become a
magnet for jihadist fighters
in the way that Afghanistan and
Iraq have been in years past.
So this is a terrible outcome.
And I believed from
the very beginning
that we should have
done what Secretary
of State Clinton and
CIA Director Petraeus
advised, which was
to arm and train
and organize the moderate
elements of the opposition,
which we're doing a
little bit of now,
but on a very small scale.
And I think given how
far the Assad regime has
gone in its atrocities
and how much support it's
received from Iran
and the Soviet-- I
was going to say
the Soviet Union.
I guess they call it
Russia these days.
But it's acting often
like the old Soviet
Union-- how much support it's
gotten from Tehran and Moscow.
I think you have
to counterbalance
that a little bit in some way.
And I think the
obvious way to do
it would be the way we did it
in Libya, by using air power
and not putting any
boots on the ground,
but simply using air power
to take down the regime's Air
Force, which has been
one of their chief tools
of staying in power.
But as we saw when President
Obama asked Congress
for support for air strikes,
there was no support.
And so that doesn't
seem to be happening.
And instead, we're going
to see this war continue,
raging unabated, which
could go on for years,
I think with terrible
humanitarian as well strategic
consequences.
AUDIENCE: Do we
know of any examples
in the past of guerrilla warfare
not in terms of insurgents,
but in terms of a
country knowingly using
this kind of warfare
against other countries,
like today's Iran and Lebanon.
And how did it end?
MAX BOOT: It happens
all the time.
I mean, how did we got
our independence, in fact?
It was largely
because the French
decided to help
the American rebels
against their
adversaries the British.
The British returned the favor
in Spain in the Peninsula War
from 1808 to 1814
when they armed
and helped the Spanish rebels.
In fact, that's where the
word guerrilla comes from,
a small war.
The Spanish battle
against Napoleon,
where the rebels had support
from the British empire
to fight the French.
It's been going on as long as
nation states have been around.
They've been using supporting
proxy forces, in essence,
against their enemies.
The Chinese and Soviets
did it to us in Vietnam.
We returned the favor against
the Soviet Union in Afghanistan
in the 1980s.
It's a tried and
true tactic, which
is why it's a little
bit puzzling to me
we're not trying to use that
tactic in the case of Syria,
because there are people there
in the Free Syrian Army who
are happy to go shoot at
both Hezbollah and al Qaeda.
They're fighting both
sides in this civil war.
And that makes them, whatever
we may think of them otherwise,
in essence our allies
in this struggle.
But we're not really
providing them
the support to go
out and do that.
And I think it would actually
be a smart thing to do,
because we wouldn't have
to put our troops at risk,
but they would do some
of our fighting for us.
It's been a classic strategy.
AUDIENCE: So this
prescription of trying
to win over the civilian
population in the country
that the insurgency is happening
seems to be a good strategy.
But how would you apply
this to a situation,
like for instance, al Qaeda,
where the organization may
be geographically distributed?
Or I'm even thinking of if you
might consider the hacker group
Anonymous like a guerrilla
warfare organization, where
there isn't really a
central location for it.
It's completely distributed.
MAX BOOT: Well, you
make a good point
in that al Qaeda is much more
international in its operations
than previous insurgent groups.
But although al Qaeda operates
in cyberspace on satellite TV
and stuff, guess what?
It's still run by
human beings who
have to live in actual
physical reality.
They can't just be
living in cyberspace.
They got to live somewhere.
They got to be able
to operate somewhere.
And where do they choose
to live and operate?
Where do they make gains?
In countries like Pakistan,
Yemen, Somalia, Libya, Mali.
In other words, all
places that don't
have effective governance, that
have insurgencies going on.
Al Qaeda basically piggy
backs and makes common cause
with the local insurgency.
And so the way to
ultimately defeat the group
is to deal with the conditions
in each country that
allow it to find
safe haven there.
It's a very hard foe
to operate against,
because they are
basically like a disease.
They're drawn by weakness.
Wherever there's ungoverned
or badly governed territory
and there is a Muslim
population there,
they will try to
make inroads there.
And so the challenge for us is,
how do we improve governance
in the Muslim world, which
right now is in upheaval?
But how do we create
effective institutions
in places like Afghanistan,
Pakistan, Iraq, Yemen, Somalia,
Libya, all these places?
Very, very hard to do, because
we're not going to go out
and sent hundreds of
thousands of US troops there.
The challenge is, how do we
work with the local governments
to enable to better
stand up and to resist
the incursions of these radical
extremists, many of them
foreigners?
That's a tough, tough challenge.
But that's what we're going to
have to do to fight al Qaeda.
And that's why it's going to
be a decades-long struggle.
It's not going to
end any time soon.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned
that guerrilla warfare
is often a response to
problems with the government
being inadequate.
So if these groups have some
sort of legitimate complaint
against the government,
isn't concentrating
on counterinsurgency putting
you on the wrong side of this?
The question is concentrating
on fixing legitimate problems.
And I was wondering also with
the hearts and minds strategy,
how much does that become a
PR battle, and how much of it
is actually addressing
the legitimate problems
that people have with
their government?
MAX BOOT: Part of it is
certainly a PR battle,
but public relations
is not going
to be effective unless you have
a good product to sell, right?
It's hard to put
lipstick on a pig
or whatever metaphor
you want to use.
And so you've got
to have something
that addresses the
actual problems.
And I think when you wage a
successful counterinsurgency
campaign, it has
to be very complex.
Because you can't simply
ignore the security component.
You can't ignore these hardcore
rebel fighters who are not
going to be appeased by any
concessions you may make,
because they may be
professional revolutionaries,
they may be jihadists
committed to death, whatever.
There's always going
to be a hard core,
whether their Marxists,
jihadists, whatever,
who are going to be fighting.
And those guys you have to
deal with by military means.
Kill or capture them.
But the vast majority
of the population
is going to be undecided.
They're going to
be saying, well,
what side should we support?
A lot of what governs
their considerations
is, which side is stronger?
But also, which side
more addresses our needs?
And so if the insurgents are
terrorizing the population,
are not addressing their
needs, the population
is going to turn against them.
That's what happened in
Iraq in Anbar province
in 2007, when the Sunnis turn
against al Qaeda in Iraq.
But conversely,
if the government
is terrorizing the population
and not addressing their needs,
the people are going to
turn against the government.
That's what's happening
in Anbar province
right now in Iraq, where the
Sunnis are once again turning
against the
Shiite-dominated government.
So you have to
have a combination.
You really have to address
some of their basic grievances.
You don't necessarily have to
grant their hardcore demands,
but you at least have to address
some of their basic grievances
that will peel off a
lot of their support.
But at the same
time, you also have
to conduct military operations
against the hard core
of the insurgency,
which is why this
is the hardest form of warfare.
It's been called the
graduate level of warfare.
It's very, very hard to wage.
It's much more difficult
than conventional conflict.
MALE SPEAKER: Wonderful.
Thanks so much for coming, Max.
MAX BOOT: Great.
Thank you very much.